[Musique]
la fusée de Blue Origin c'est bien
envolé cet après-midi à son bord un
passager emblématique William Shatner
qui a incarné le mythique capitaine Kirk
de la série Star Trek à 90 ans il est
devenu la personne la plus âgée à
atteindre l'espace il s'agit du deuxième
vol avec des passagers à bord pour la
fusée de l'entreprise du milliardaire
Jeff Bezos le vol a duré 11 minutes
montre en main et le capitaine Kirk est
revenu sur terre sans encombre il a
embarquait dans la fusée de Jeff Bezos
c'est celle-ci qui non ne comptez pas
sur moi pour dire que cette fusée
ressemble à ce à quoi on pense tous en
la voyant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez penser à quoi ce fait
William la même chose que vous vous
trompez bah Vous vous trompez non c'est
un cornichon
là-bas d'Espagne ou on cultive le plus
de connexion
mais on n'est pas obligé de le dessiner
à ce point oui de cette manière là ils
entendent des éclats de rire de l'autre
côté
des amours
familial selon une récente étude une
personne sur quatre en couple admet
avoir eu envie de rompre avec son
conjoint pendant la crise sanitaire un
chiffre qui monte jusqu'à 50% pour les
hommes de moins de 30 ans des envies de
séparation dues entre autres un manque
de communication une baisse de libido ou
encore la présence des enfants à la
maison qu'on vit une vague de changement
intime on est tous en train de
s'interroger sur qu'est-ce que je fais
après
c'est Milo c'est
[Musique]
c'est super gênant ça rend pas compte
c'est avocate reçoit près de 10 nouveaux
dossiers par mois avec des demandes de
séparation plus radicales et plus
brutales qu'auparavant les gens qui
m'ont téléphoné mon mari est parti en
disant
moi je pourrai pas rester avec toi je
pendant deux mois et demi et je
t'annonce que j'ai une maîtresse donc je
pars chez elle des Mureaux en pleine
reproduction au milieu d'un nuage de
fécondé avec cette photo exceptionnelle
d'un phénomène qui se produit une fois
par an
le français de Laurent ba les stars
remporté le premier prix du photographe
de nature de l'année le prestigieux
concours wide life photographe of the
year a également distingué cette
effrayant cliché d'une araignée banane
découverte sous un lit veillant sur ses
petits ainsi que la déprimante photo
d'un éléphant dans un zoo en Thaïlande
gros plan sur Shirley voici
la tortue
[Applaudissements]
n'en faites pas plus
c'est un fardeau qu'il portait depuis au
moins deux ans ce week-end de les
services en charge de la faune du
Colorado on libère et ce wapiti du pneu
coincé autour de son cours sur les
réseaux sociaux ils expliquent qu'il a
fallu endormir l'animal et lui couper
les bois pour le libérer rien de
définitif ces bois se renouvelle chaque
année depuis l'été 2019 le mammifère
avait été aperçu plusieurs fois avec cet
encombrant collier de 16 kg et les
gardes forestiers avaient tenté quatre
fois de lui retirer la cinquième fut la
bonne après l'hippocampe et le
coton-tige cher au fils de bavette
Lemoine le poisson avec la cigarette
cher à Elise Lucet le wapiti et son pneu
nous rappelle la nécessité de respecter
la faune et la flore et ça c'est très
important et le pneu est devenu quoi
alors il faut savoir qu'il met de
l'acier dans le pneu et on l'arrangeait
regardez cette image qui a beaucoup
tourné sur les réseaux sociaux ceci
n'est pas une œuvre d'art mais c'est
bien un kangoo soigneusement garé sur un
abribus les gendarmes ont percé le
mystère cet après-midi un agriculteur en
conflit avec un voisin à utiliser son
tracteur pour lui faire une mauvaise
blague il s'est engagé à rembourser tous
les frais liés à sa vengeance farfelue
mais il reste une question
je sais pas s'il y a des amendes pour le
stationnement sur abruti nos policiers
aujourd'hui font un travail déplorable
un travail admirable pardon un travail
admirable mais dans des conditions qui
sont déplorables déplorables dans des
conditions qui sont déplorables bon Éric
Zemmour
je me suis trompé
Eric Revel année hier Emmanuel Macron
présentait son plan France 2030 je peux
vous dire que ce n'est rien mais alors
rien à côté de la cérémonie organisée en
début de semaine par Kim Jong-un et
saurez-vous retrouver qui n'avait pas
reçu les informations concernant le
dress code
[Musique]
je crois que je l'ai trouvé
pantalon rouge cerise
ouais est-ce que de la vérité viens voir
mon fils est-ce que tu aimes ce jean
dis-moi la vérité tu aimes bien
c'est comme ça que tu reçois les clients
ouais je reçois comme ça moi j'aime bien
être
même si on n'a pas trop de clients
par une dette sucrée on fait du chocolat
des fruits découpés vu que ici c'est un
peu la galère et qu'on a pas de
cure-dent on met des cotons-tiges sur
les bananes pour qu'il puisse les
attraper franchement c'est trop beau non
il faut arrêter à revenir des choses
assez simples comme de manger équilibré
je préfère encore comme ça un message
manger 5 fruits et légumes par jour
qu'on commence à me [__] des études
sur tous les produits
personne
regardez ce que vous avez gagné
l'indispensable boîte de petits pois
toujours utile dans un placard quand il
n'y a plus rien dans le frigo avec la
boîte de petits pois les carottes ne
sont jamais cuites le cadeau mythique
par contre
je sais pas du coup
[Musique]
comment on n'ose pas trop la gratter par
rapport si c'était du costaud vous avez
peur de passer au travers voilà celle-là
vous allez tous les jours bien sûr c'est
une fois par jour
moi j'ai tendance à
pas y aller tout le temps non
le matin et soir c'est important voilà
le matin
je me dis qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi
une production
j'adore aller me peser je dis là si je
vais pas tarder 1 kg
j'ai perdu du poids est-ce qu'on est pas
trop intime tout ça non pas du tout